FEMALE SPEAKER: The following
content is provided under a
Creative Commons License.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or to view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Hi.
Technically speaking, I suppose,
if time permitted, we
should spend, or shall we say,
give equal time to integral
calculus, the same time that
we gave to differential
calculus, starting from scratch,
building ideas slowly
and the like.
But there are two logistic
reasons for not doing this,
one of which is that the basic
definitions would be the same
regardless of which branch
we started with.
The second one is, of course,
that time becomes preciously
tight, and we have to make the
best of what we can here.
So what we're going to do now
is try to show, in terms of
hindsight being better than
foresight, a motivation as to
how one would have invented
differential calculus had it
been motivated by the existing
integral calculus.
In other words, what we want
to do today is to show the
beautiful interplay between
differential
and integral calculus.
Since we have said in our last
lecture that we would like to
begin with a study of integral
calculus, assuming that
differential calculus had never
been invented, I think
that we're obligated to try to
show how, then, differential
calculus could have been
invented in the environment of
the studying of areas.
For this reason, I have called
today's lecture "The Marriage
of Differential and Integral
Calculus." And essentially,
the idea goes something
like this.
Last time, we were talking
about finding
areas under a curve.
And to find the area under the
curve, we saw that we could do
this as the limit of
a certain sum.
In other words, an infinite sum
having a particular limit.
Now, to motivate the concept of
rate of change, one could
ask the following question.
A curve like 'y' equals 'f of
x', and a starting point, 'x'
equals 'a'.
As I move out along the x-axis
from 'a', I could study the
area under the curve, say, of
the curve, 'y' equals 'f of
x', from 'x' equals 'a'
to some value 'x1'.
And the question I could then
ask is, I wonder how fast this
area is changing at the instant
that 'x' equals 'x1'.
In other words, how fast is the
area changing under the
curve as 'x' moves out along the
positive x-axis this way?
You see?
Now, the idea is this.
I can then mimic the same
definition that we gave for
instantaneous rate of change
and differential calculus.
Namely, I can say, why can't
we define the instantaneous
rate of change to be the average
rate of change with
respect to 'x'?
And then we'll take the
limit as 'delta x'
approaches 0, et cetera.
And if I do that, watch what
happens over here.
You see what I do in terms of
this picture, is I say, OK,
here's the area under
the curve when
'x' is equal to 'x1'.
Now I'll let 'x1' change by some
amount 'delta x', meaning
this'll be the point
'x1 + delta x'.
And this brings about a change
in my area, which
I'll call 'delta A'.
See the change in area
as 'x' goes from 'x1'
to 'x1 + delta x'.
Now, what I would like to find
is 'delta A' divided by 'delta
x', taking the limit as 'delta
x' approaches 0.
Remember, last time we
showed our three
basic axioms for area.
We're obliged to
still use them.
Let's do that here.
For example, the way I've drawn
this curve by rising
this way, notice that the lowest
point in this interval
occurs when 'x' equals 'x1'.
The highest point occurs when
'x' equals 'x1 + delta x'.
Consequently, the rectangle
whose base is the closed
interval from 'x1' to 'x1 +
delta x', the rectangle whose
height corresponds to 'x' equals
'x1' is too small in
area to be 'delta A'.
In other words, that rectangle
is inscribed in 'delta A'.
And in the same way, the
rectangle, with base 'x1' to
'x1 + delta x', whose height is
given by the x-coordinate,
'x1 + delta x', that rectangle
has an area which is too large
to be the exact area.
In other words, notice that
the area of the rectangle,
which is too small to be the
exact area, is 'f of x1'
times 'delta x'.
The area of the rectangle which
is too big to be the
correct 'delta A' is 'f of 'x1
+ delta x'' times 'delta x'.
And the area, 'delta A', is
caught between these two.
In other words, we now have the
inequality that 'f of x1'
times 'delta x' is less than
'delta A', which in turn is
less than 'f of 'x1 + delta
x'' times 'delta x'.
Now, we'll assume that 'delta x'
is positive, the way we've
drawn it in this diagram.
Adjustments have to be made if
'delta x' is negative, in
other words, if we let
'delta x' approach 0
through negative values.
This is taken care of in the
textbook, as well as mentioned
in our notes.
But for the sake of just getting
the main idea here,
we'll assume that 'delta
x' is positive.
We divide through
by 'delta x'.
That gives us 'f of x1' is
less than 'delta a' over
'delta x', which in turn
is less than 'f
of 'x1 + delta x''.
In other words, had 'delta x'
been negative, we would have
had to reverse the inequality
signs, et cetera, but we're
not going to worry about
that right now.
Remember, what is 'delta x'?
It's a non-zero number which is
going to be made to become
arbitrarily close to 0.
Well, here's the idea.
We now have 'delta a' over
'delta x' squeezed between
these two values.
And we say, OK, let's let
'delta x' approach 0.
Now, here's the key point.
As 'delta x' approaches 0,
certainly, 'x1 + delta x'
approaches 'x1'.
And here's where we use the fact
that 'f' is continuous.
In other words, notice that the
mere fact that 'x1 + delta
x' approaches 'x1' is not enough
to say, therefore, that
'f of 'x1 + delta x'' approaches
'f of x1'.
As we saw before, that's only
true if 'f' is continuous.
In other words, by continuity,
if 'x1 + delta x' approaches
'x1', then 'f of 'x1 + delta
x'' approaches 'f of x1'.
So assuming, then, that 'f' is
continuous, what do we get we
put the squeeze on?
'x1' is what's picked
to be a fixed point.
Consequently, as 'delta
x' approaches 0, 'f of
x1' stays 'f of x1'.
'f of 'x1 + delta x'' approaches
'f of x1'.
In other words, 'delta A'
divided by 'delta x' is caught
between two numbers, two
sequences, two sets of bounds,
whichever way you want to say
this, both of which converge
to the common limit,
'f of x1'.
In other words, since 'delta A'
over 'delta x' is squeezed
between these two, the limit of
'delta a' over 'delta x',
as 'delta x' approaches 0, must
equal this common limit.
In other words, 'dA/dx', the
limit of 'delta A' over 'delta
x', as 'delta x' approaches 0,
evaluated at 'x' equals 'x1',
is 'f of x1'.
Or another way of saying this,
'dA/dx' is 'f of x'.
Now, that result is partly
intuitive and partly
remarkable.
What it says is, roughly
speaking, is that the area
under the curve is changing at
a rate equal instantaneously
to the height corresponding
to the
x-coordinate at that point.
In other words, to define how
fast the area is changing as
'x' moves, all you have to do
is measure the height of the
curve corresponding to that
particular value of 'x'.
Now, what does this have to
do, then, with relating
integral and differential
calculus?
Notice already we begin to
get some sort of a hint.
What we've shown is now that
the area is going to be
related somehow to the inverse
derivative of 'f of x'.
In fact, this is precisely
what is meant by a rather
important result.
In fact, it's important enough
so it's called the first
fundamental theorem of
integral calculus.
And it simply says this.
Suppose we know explicitly a
function, capital 'G', such
that the derivative of capital
'G' is 'f', where the 'f' now
refers to the 'f' that we're
talking about in our problem.
Now, look it, what we already
know is that 'A', the area
function, has its derivative
equal to 'f'.
Consequently, since the area
function and G have the same
derivative, they must differ
by, at most, a constant.
In other words, the area as
a function of 'x' is this
function, 'G of x' plus 'c'.
And what is this 'G of x'?
It's not any old function.
It's what?
An inverse derivative
of 'f of x'.
Since the area evaluated at
'x' equals 'a' is 0, see,
namely, the area under the
curve, as 'x' goes from 'A' to
'a', see, that's just a line.
A line has no thickness,
has no area.
This is 0.
We have, by plugging back
in to here, that 'A' of
little 'a' is 0.
That in turn is 'G
of a' plus 'c'.
And solving this for 'c', we
find that 'c' is equal to
minus 'G of a'.
In other words, the area under
the curve 'y' equals 'f of x',
as a function of 'x',
is simply what?
It's 'G of x' minus 'G of a',
where 'G' is any function
whose derivative is 'f'.
If we now let 'x' equal 'b',
we're back to the situation of
finding the usual region that
we're talking about here,
namely, what is 'A sub R'?
It's the region bounded above--
let's come back here
and take a look at this-- it's
the region bounded above by
the curve, 'y' equals 'f of x',
bounded on the left by 'x'
equals 'a', on the right by 'x'
equals 'b', and below by
the x-axis.
According to this notation, the
area of the region 'R' is
just the area as a function of
'x' when 'x1' is equal to 'b'.
In other words, the area of our
region 'R' is just 'a' of
'b', which is 'G of b' minus
'G of a', where 'G' is any
function whose derivative
is 'f'.
Now remember--
and here's the key point--
remember that the area of the
region 'R' did not necessitate
us having to know a function
whose derivative was 'f'.
In other words, remember, in our
last lecture, how did we
find areas of regions
like 'R'?
What we did was is we formed
these 'U sub n's,
these 'L sub n's.
We inscribed and circumscribed
networks of rectangles, put
the squeeze on by evaluating
this particular limit.
And whatever that limit was,
that was the area of the
region 'R'.
In other words, if I had never
heard of the inverse
derivative, I could still
find the area of the
region 'R' this way.
However, if I just happen to
know a function 'G', whose
derivative is 'f', I have a much
easier way of doing this.
In fact, let me summarize
that.
You see, we can compute
the limit as
'n' approaches infinity.
Summation 'k' goes from 1 to
'n', 'f of 'c sub k'' 'delta
x', by use of inverse
derivatives.
See, again, the highlight
being what?
You can still work with this the
same way as we did in our
last lecture.
There is absolutely no need to
have had to ever heard of a
derivative to solve this
type of problem, even
though it may be messy.
Now, what's the best proof
I have of this?
Well, I guess one of the best
proofs is to specifically
refer to one of the exercises
in the previous unit.
It was a tough exercise.
I did it as a learning exercise
because I felt it was
something that was messy and
that you had to be guided
through in order not to become
hopelessly lost.
By way of review, the
problem was this.
We took as our region 'R' the
region bounded above by 'y'
equals 'sine x', below by the
x-axis, on the right by the
line 'x' equals pi/2.
And the problem was, define the
area of the region 'R'.
And we solved this problem in
the last unit without recourse
to derivatives because, as of
the time that we were in the
last unit, we had no results
relating derivatives
to limits of sums.
How did we do this?
We partitioned this into n
parts, and we formed the sum
limit as 'n' approaches
infinity.
'Sigma k' goes from 1 to 'n'.
We broke this thing up into 'n'
equal parts, so the size
of each piece was what?
pi/2 divided by 'n'.
That's 'pi/2n'.
We computed the sine of each of
these n-points, et cetera.
And whatever that limit was,
that was the area of the
region 'R'.
And as you recall, that homework
problem, we found
that the answer to that problem
was that the area of
the region 'R' was 1.
Now again, as messy as that was,
it proved that we could
at least solve the problem
with no knowledge of
derivatives.
How does the first fundamental
theorem apply here?
The way the first fundamental
theorem
applies is the following.
The first fundamental
theorem says this.
Look it, to evaluate this
particular sum, all we have to
do is find a function whose
derivative is 'sine x'.
See, notice in this problem, the
general 'a' and 'b' of the
above is now played by 'a'
equals 0 and 'b' equals pi/2.
All we have to do is what?
Find the function 'G' whose
derivative is 'sine x', and
the answer should then be 'G
of pi/2' minus 'G of 0'.
Well, you see this happens
to be one that, with our
knowledge of differential
calculus, we
can do rather easily.
In other words, do we, at the
tip of our tongues, have a
function whose derivative
is 'sine x'?
And the answer is yes.
Since the derivative of 'cosine
x' is 'minus sine x',
the derivative of 'minus
cosine x' is 'sine x'.
In other words, we can choose
for our 'G of x' here
'minus cosine x'.
In other words, that the
area of the region
'R' should be what?
'G of pi/2' minus 'G of
0', where 'G of x' is
'minus cosine x'.
Well, you see, cosine
pi/2 is 0.
Cosine of 0 is 1, so 0 minus
minus 1 is equal to 1.
And notice that, first of all,
we get the same answer.
And secondly, notice this
two-line job over here.
We not only get the correct
answer, but we get the answer
very much more rapidly
than we did by the
so-called limit process.
Now, I'll come back to this in a
minute, because you may be a
little bit angry at me now.
Namely, you may be asking,
after having to do this
problem the hard way, why did
I have to do the usual
teacher's trick here and show
you the hard way of doing this
and then waiting until the next
unit before I show you
the easy way?
Well, there happens to be a
catch here that I'll come back
to in just a moment.
But before I do that, I'd like
to make an aside, an aside
that's rather important.
Namely, you may recall, as I
started to work over here,
that this reminded you of a
notation that we were using
back when we introduced the
concept of the inverse of
differentiation.
Namely, we earlier used a
notation, integral from 'a' to
'b', 'f of x' 'dx' to denote 'G
of b' minus 'G of a', where
'G prime' equals 'f'.
What we have shown by the first
fundamental theorem,
then, using this notation, is
that the area of the region
'R' is integral from 'a'
to 'b', 'f of x' 'dx'.
In other words, this
means what?
It means 'G of b' minus
'G of a', where 'G
prime' equals 'f'.
OK, let's pause here
for a moment.
See, as we developed
our course, this is
how this would evolve.
The interesting thing is that,
historically, this notation
was not used to define 'G of
b' minus 'G of a', where 'G
prime' equaled 'f'.
Historically, what happened was
that this notation, called
the definite integral, the
integral from 'a' to 'b', 'f
of x' 'dx', was--
I don't know if it's proper to
say invented, but let me just
say it in quotation marks
to play it safe--
it was "invented" to denote
the limit of this sum.
In fact, notice how much more
meaningful the symbol looks in
this connotation.
In other words, this is
the limit of a sum.
You can think of sum as
beginning with 's', and the
integral of sine as
an elongated 's'.
In other words, when one first
wrote this symbol, the
definite integral, it was meant
to denote this limit.
The important point is that,
by the first fundamental
theorem, the definite integral,
whether it's a limit
or not, turns out to be 'G of
b' minus 'G of a', where 'G
prime' equals 'f'.
In other words, it really makes
no difference in terms
of what answer you get, whether
you think of this
definite integral as meaning
this, or whether you think of
the definite integral
as meaning this.
See, numerically, they'll
be the same.
But conceptually, they're
quite different.
And that's precisely the point
that leads to the most, I
think, probably the most
difficult part all the course,
at least up until now.
It's something that more
people cause and have
misinterpretation over.
And so I'd like to present
this in a very,
very gradual way.
See, the result will ultimately
be known as the
second fundamental theorem
of integral calculus.
I've taken the liberty of
writing that over here.
But it's going to be quite a
while before I actually say
what the theorem
is explicitly.
What I'd like to do is to pick
up where I left off when I
made my aside about
the notation
of a definite integral.
And what I'd like to mention
now is, for the person who
says, look it, why did
you make us find the
areas the hard way?
Why didn't you just say let us
compute 'G of b' minus 'G of
a', where 'G prime' equals 'f',
and the heck with all
this summation process?
Now, I think the best way to
answer that question--
and this is probably the
ultimate in teaching
technique, when somebody thinks
that he has an easier
way than the way that
he was taught--
give them a problem that can't
be done by that easier way.
In fact, as a sarcastic aside,
if you can't invent that kind
of a problem, maybe the
so-called easier way is the
better way of doing a thing.
But let me just show you what
I'm driving at over here.
Suppose I say to you, let's find
the area of the region
'R' where 'R' is now
the following.
It's bounded above by the
curve, 'y' equals '1/x'.
It's bounded below
by the x-axis.
It's bounded on the left by the
line, 'x' equals 1, and on
the right by the line,
'x' equals 2.
I would like to find the area
of this region 'R'.
Now look it, from a purely
conceptual point of view, what
difference is there between this
problem and the problem
where the upper curve was
'y' equals 'x squared'?
Conceptually, what's going
on is the same thing.
We have a bounded region and we
want to compute the area.
To this end, notice that, if I
use the precise definition of
a definite integral, the area
of the region 'R' is what?
The definite integral
from 1 to 2, 'dx/x'.
What does that mean?
It means a particular limit.
What limit?
Well, you partition this
integral from 1 to 2 into n
equal parts, pick a point, 'c
sub k' in each partition, then
'f of 'c sub k'' in this problem
is just '1/'c sub k''.
In other words, what we want
to do is to compute this
limit. 'Sigma k' goes from
1 to 'n', '1/'c sub k'',
times 'delta x'.
Now, the thing to notice is,
this thing may be a mess but
it's computable.
We could use specially designed
graph paper or
measuring devices to count the
units of area under here.
We can find all sorts of ways of
getting estimates, even the
long hard way of the 'U sub
n's and the 'L sub n's to
pinpoint the area of the region
'R' to as close a
degree of accuracy as
we want, et cetera.
The point is that, if we have
never heard of a derivative,
the area of the region 'R' is
given precisely by this sum.
And admittedly, the
sum is a mess.
So let's try to do it the
so-called easier way.
The skeptic looks at
this thing and
says, who needs this?
The area of the region 'R',
we just saw by the first
fundamental theorem, is 'G of
2', 'G of 2', minus 'G of 1',
where 'G' is any function of
'x' whose derivative with
respect to 'x' is '1/x'.
And the answer to that is yes.
So far, so good.
But do we know a function 'G'
whose derivative with respect
to 'x' is '1/x'?
Remember, this is calculus
revisited.
For those of you who remember
calculus from
the first time around--
and I'll talk about
this later--
it's going to turn out that
the required 'G' is a
logarithmic function.
For those of you don't remember
that, there's no harm
in not remembering that.
All I'm trying to bring out is
that, whether you remember it
or you don't, as far as we're
concerned so far in this
course, as far as what we've
developed in this course, we
do not know a function 'G' whose
derivative with respect
to 'x' is '1/x'.
That's what we mean by saying
we can't exhibit 'G'
explicitly.
What do I mean by that?
Somebody says, I am thinking
of a function whose
derivative is '1/x'.
I say, well, that's simple.
It's 'G of x'.
He says, well, what's
'G of x'?
I say, that's the function whose
derivative with respect
to 'x' is '1/x'.
Well, you see, that implicitly
tells me what 'G' is like.
But in terms of concrete
measurements, I don't know
anything about 'G'.
I can't express it in terms of
well-known, familiar functions.
You see, I'm hung up now.
Namely, this is precise.
The answer to this problem will
be 'G of 2' minus 'G of
1', where 'G prime' is '1/x'.
But I don't know explicitly--
yikes--
I don't know, explicitly
such a 'G'.
And I put the exclamation point
out here to emphasize
that particular fact.
That's the hang-up.
The statement that says that the
area is 'G of b' minus 'G
of a', where 'G prime' equals
'f' hinges on the fact that
you can explicitly exhibit
such as 'G'.
Certainly, if you can't exhibit
that 'G', you can
still compute this
area as a limit.
It would be tragic to say, oh,
the area doesn't exist because
I don't know a 'G' whose
derivative is '1/x'.
Certainly, this region
'R' has an area.
In fact, because we can pinpoint
the area of the
region 'R', we can actually
construct the 'G' such that 'G
prime of x' equals '1/x'.
And by the way, there's plenty
of drill on this.
This is a hard concept.
And as a result, you'll notice
that the exercises in this
section hammer home on this
point, because it's a point
that I'm positive that, if
you're having trouble at all
with integral calculus, this
is certainly the most
sophisticated part of what
we're doing right now.
You see, look it, suppose I want
to construct a function
'G' whose derivative is '1/x'.
The idea looks something
like this.
I'm on the interval
from 1 to 2 here.
What I do is, I plot the curve,
'y' equals '1/x'.
And I compute the area of the
region formed by the curve,
'y' equals '1/x'.
'x' equals 1.
The x-axis and the line,
'x' equals 'x1'.
This is my region 'R'.
And what I say is, look
it, what do I
know about this area?
Remember, what I started this
lecture with was the knowledge
that a prime of 'x' is 'f
of x'. 'f of x', in
this case, is '1/x'.
In other words, what property
does this area function have?
It has the property that its
derivative with respect to 'x'
is going to be '1/x'.
In other words, if I now say,
look it, boys, I can compute
this area, if not exactly, at
least to as many decimal place
accuracy as I wish, so that the
area function is something
I can construct.
Let me define 'G of x1' simply
to be the area under this
curve when 'x' is
equal to 'x1'.
In other words, written
now as a limit--
see how this definite integral
comes in here--
written as integral from 1 to 'x
sub 1', 'dx/x', which I now
can compute as closely
as I want as a limit.
The beauty is what?
That 'G prime of x1' is, by
definition, 'A prime of 'x1'.
And we have already seen that
the derivative of 'A' is 'f',
where 'f' is the top curve.
In this case, the derivative
of 'A' is '1/x'.
In other words, the area under
the curve explicitly can be
computed as a function of 'x'.
And that function has the
property, but its derivative
with respect to 'x', in
this case, is '1/x'.
And by the way, let me make just
a quick aside over here.
I happened to throw in the
word "logarithms" before.
It's going to turn out, as we'll
talk about in our next
block of material, that 'G of x'
turns out to be the natural
log of 'x', which means that the
area of the region 'R' is
precisely natural log 2.
Now, the idea is--
and this is exactly what's going
to happen in our last
block in our course--
that this is exactly how
the log tables are
constructed, in fact.
I mean, how do you think they
find the log of 2 to eight
decimal places?
Did they strand somebody on a
desert island and tell them to
compute these things, measure
it with laser beams, what?
No.
The way we do it is, we know
it's an area, and knowing how
to find the area as a limit to
as many decimal place accuracy
as we wish, give or take a few
tricks of the trade, this is
how we find logs, and later
on, trigonometric
tables, and the like.
But I just mention this as
an aside to show you how
important knowing area
under a curve is.
At any rate, to summarize what
we're saying over here, we
have the following.
In general, if 'f' is any
continuous function on the
closed interval from 'a' to 'b',
we define a function 'G'
as follows.
'G of x1' is the definite
integral from 'a' to 'x1', 'f
of x' 'dx', where 'x1' is any
point in the closed interval
for 'a' to 'b'.
What does this thing mean,
geometrically?
It's the area under the curve,
'y' equals 'f of x' on top.
'x' equals the x-axis on the
bottom, the line 'x' equals
'a' on the left, the line 'x'
equals 'x1' on the right.
And that area is what?
It's the limit as 'n'
approaches infinity.
'Sigma k' goes from 1 to 'n', 'f
of 'c sub k'' 'delta x', et
cetera, et cetera, et cetera,
meaning we can go through this
the same way as we did in
our previous lecture.
This function, 'G of x1'--
which we can now compute
explicitly as an area, because
we have the curve 'f' drawn,
we can approximate it to as
close a degree of accuracy
as we want--
whatever that function 'G' is,
what property does it have?
It has the property that 'G
prime' is equal to 'f'.
And that's exactly what the
second fundamental theorem
really means.
The second fundamental theorem
says, look it, if you can
compute the area, you can now
reverse this procedure that
we're talking about in the first
fundamental theorem.
See, in the first fundamental
theorem, what did we do?
In the first fundamental
theorem, we found a quick way
of computing the area as
a limit by knowing the
appropriate inverse
derivative.
The second fundamental theorem,
in a sense, is the
inverse of the first fundamental
theorem.
Namely, it switches the roles.
Namely, with the second
fundamental theorem, what we
say is this.
If we know how to find the
area under the curve, 'y'
equals 'f of x', that gives us
a way of computing a function
'G' whose derivative is 'f'.
In fact, to summarize this--
and I think this is
very important.
Let me just summarize
this, then.
First of all, the first
fundamental theorem allows us
to compute this particular
limit, provided we can find a
'G', such that 'G prime'
equals 'f'.
In fact, in this case, the
limit, as 'n' approaches
infinity, summation 'k' goes
from 1 to 'n', 'f of 'c sub
k'' 'delta x', is given very,
very ingeniously, beautifully,
and concisely by 'G of
b' minus 'G of a'.
Secondly, the second fundamental
theorem allows us,
given 'f', to construct
'G', such that 'G
prime' equals 'f'.
Namely, the required 'G' is
just the definite integral
from 'a' to 'x1', 'f of x' 'dx',
which in turn is a limit
of a network of rectangles,
namely the limit as 'n'
approaches infinity, summation
'k' goes from 1 to 'n', 'f of
'c sub k'' times 'delta x'.
This then is perhaps the most
beautiful lecture in calculus,
not necessarily the
way I've given it,
but in terms of what?
Relating two apparently diverse
branches of calculus,
integral and differential
calculus.
This is a difficult subject.
I have taken great pains to try
to write this clearly in
the supplementary notes.
I have tried to pick typical
exercises that bring home
these highlights.
And in addition, our next two
lectures will emphasize the
relationship between derivatives
and integrals as
we study volume and
arc length.
At any rate, until next
time, goodbye.
MALE SPEAKER: Funding for the
publication of this video was
provided by the Gabriella and
Paul Rosenbaum Foundation.
Help OCW continue to provide
free and open access to MIT
courses by making a donation
at ocw.mit.edu/donate.